ja und wir gehen und bleiben in berlin
und dort steht schon mein kollege erhard
scherfer es geht nämlich heute im
bundestag um die befragung der
bundesregierung und insbesondere heute
befragung des bundeskanzlers nämlich
immer vor ostern vor der sommerpause und
vor weihnachten ist der kanzler dran und
muss seine politik erklären was wird
denn dort heute eine rolle spielen herr
schärfer ist es dann nur die ukraine
oder wird das dann auch noch mal eben
zum beispiel das was kein lauterbach
angesprochen hat könnte das auch noch
eine rolle spielen
ich sags mal so bernd rasen wir haben
120 tage ampelkoalitionen das heißt wir
haben auch 120 tage bundeskanzler
scholze hat sich schon das eine und
andere thema angesammelt in diesen in
diesen monaten nicht nur ukraine sondern
beispielsweise auch die impfpflicht die
hier morgen abschließend beraten werden
wird und wo es in den vergangenen tagen
jedoch noch einiges an bewegung gegeben
hat aber im mittelpunkt mutmaßlich heute
haben wir ja immerhin 42 tage lang krieg
gegen die ukraine wir haben 39 tage der
sogenannten zeitenwende die der
bundeskanzler ausgerufen hat am 27
februar hier in der sondersitzung des
bundestags und heute steht er nun den
abgeordneten zum zweiten mal in diesem
jahr rhede und hoffentlich auch antwort
und wir werfen vorab aber schon mal
einen blick auf diese sogenannte
zeitenwende und ihre folgen und das tun
wir mit nils schmid dem außenpolitischen
sprecher der spd-fraktion ihnen einen
schönen guten tag und ich begrüße
johann war doch wohl fragen sie mich
jetzt nicht warum ich da jetzt
gestolpert bin johann wadephul ist der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unions-fraktion und zuständig und gut im
bild zu den themen außen- sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitik auch ihnen
schöntag ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch
wieder ich werde normalerweise sage ich
hier guten morgen das funktioniert um
diese zeit aber nicht wenn wir wieder
ernst und der situation angemessen eine
zeitenwende das stichwort habe ich schon
genannt wie viel hat herr schmid die
koalition wie viel hat aber auch die
bundesregierung bislang dafür getan um
dieser zeitenwende gerecht zu werden
eine menge also wir haben ja den
bundeshaushalt er in vorbereitung ist
die grundgesetzänderung für das
sondervermögen 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr ist in vorbereitung wir
werden also in den nächsten wochen diese
sondervermögen beschließen und damit die
bundeswehr besser ausrüsten wir haben in
der nato besprochen dass auch die
bundeswehr sich an der schutz der an dem
schutz der ostflanke im baltikum in
anderen östlichen nato staaten beteiligt
und vor allem haben wir mit
waffenlieferungen die ukraine in die
lage versetzt besser gegen den
russischen angriff vorzugehen das ist
gute mannschaft viele stichworte
dringliche sowieso auf meinem zettel
haben die wären wir gleich mal vertiefen
herr wadephul was wollen sie heute
wissen vom bundeskanzler ja überhaupt
das einmal wieder stellung nimmt
gegenüber dem deutschen bundestag hat
eine große rede gehalten am 27 februar
danach erscheint er hier nicht allzu
häufig bundeskanzlerin merkel hat nahezu
zu jedem eu-gipfel eine
regierungserklärung gehalten
wir haben jetzt einen neuen traurigen
schrecklichen höhepunkt des ukraine
krieges mit den massakern butscher und
ich hatte mir eigentlich auch gewünscht
dass der bundeskanzler dazu morgen auch
im deutschen bundestag in form einer
regierungserklärung das wort ergreift
aber wir werden ihn jetzt dazu fragen in
der tat bemerkenswert der kollege schmid
hat es gesagt die bundesregierung hat
hat die zeitenwende eingeläutet das ist
ganz was anderes als was im
koalitionsvertrag drin stand was man
sich vorgenommen hatte aber in der tat
man hat eine anpassung vorgenommen die
union unterstützt das im prinzip aber
wir wollen natürlich jetzt auch
einzelheiten wissen was geschieht
konkret damit die ukraine sich wirklich
wirkungsvoll verteidigen kann wir werden
auch auf diesen punkt ja noch mal gucken
ganz wichtige diskussion in den
vergangenen tagen ist unter anderem
gewesen dass viele ehemalige spd
minister in amt und würden oder auch
jetzt der jetzige bundespräsident sich
geäußert haben zu russland politik auch
die mecklenburg-vorpommersche
ministerpräsidentin schwesig hat fehler
eingeräumt der bundespräsident auch in
der russland politik wäre herr schmid
musste ich noch alles äußern in dieser
klarheit ich glaube alle in deutschland
die in den letzten jahren verantwortung
getragen haben auch kanzlerin merkel zum
beispiel
haben die russlandpolitik zu
verantworten und man sollte sich auch
nicht täuschen es waren damals auch
andere umstände und man hat damals nach
besten wissen und gewissen gehandelt ich
würde das niemanden ab sprechen weder
frau merkel noch von walter steinmeier
umso wichtiger ist es dass man dann auch
entschlossen umsteuert nachdem das
bisherige verhältnis zu russland durch
boutiquen zerstört worden ist und
entsprechend ist es gut dass jetzt olaf
scholz gehandelt hat sigmar gabriel und
heiko maas nicht erwähnt die beiden
außenminister der letzten beiden
legislaturperioden gehe ja auch
unterschiedlichen umgang gepflegt haben
mit russland und mit wladimir putin ja
aber ich finde jetzt nicht dass
sozusagen jeder sich äußern muss ich
finde es gut wenn bundespräsident
steiner ist tut entscheidend ist das
handeln der jetzigen regierung und da
hat scholz und klaren kurs vorgegeben
den wie auch in der breite der koalition
unterstützen so ein bisschen
aufarbeitung und noch mal sagen warum
haben wir so entschieden
was zu dieser heutigen situation auch
mit geführt haben könnte zumindest gerd
schröder würde ich auch gerne mal hören
beispielsweise wird man hin und wieder
aber
ich glaube entscheidend ist wirklich
dass wir aus der erfahrung unsere
beziehung zu russland lernen für den
umgang mit anderen autoritären regimen
wir wissen ja nicht wie sich das
verhältnis zu china beispielsweise
weiterentwickelt und die herausforderung
durch china technologisch ökonomisch
aber auch sicherheitspolitisch ist noch
von einer anderen dimension als die von
russland wir wissen dass handel durch
wandel durch handel im verhältnis zu
russland immer weniger gebracht hat
zuletzt gar nichts mehr und
entsprechende fragen müssen wir uns auch
in china stellen und daraus die
schlussfolgerung zu ziehen ich glaube
das ist jetzt die aufgabe also aus der
vergangenheit lernen für den umgang mit
anderen herausforderungen wie zum
beispiel china beiden herr walter vohl
hören würde er noch mal was von der alt
kanzlerin zu diesem thema und ihrer
rolle und ihren gedanken die sie sich zu
jener zeit gemacht hat weil es ist ja
durchaus was dran an dem was herr
schmidt sagt irgendwie wir haben wir
sind von anderen voraussetzungen
ausgegangen aber die kann man ja
trotzdem erklären ja natürlich
dass wir die kanzlerin selber
entscheiden wann und wie sie sich
äußerst dann würden sie gerne mal hören
sondern natürlich also ich habe
vergangenen tagen die bitte geäußert
dass der bundespräsident sich äußert
wahrscheinlich auf mich reagiert aber er
hat sich gemeldet frauen ukrainische
botschafter ja der hat ihn sehr stark
angegriffen ich bin insgesamt jammern
wir sollten schon auf arbeiten als
deutscher bundestag ich kann mir
vorstellen dass wir eine ranke
kommission zu dieser frage mal einsetzen
weil in der tat da stimme ich dem
kollegen schmidt zu ich finde alle haben
an dass das aufzuarbeiten
wir sind aber auch von anderen annahmen
ausgegangen und die frage ist ja was
lernt man aus fehlern das ist ja im
normalen leben so dass es auch im
politischen leben so wir haben übrigens
noch zwei fraktionen ganz links ganz
rechts die heute noch nichts darüber
davon lernen wollen noch ein
unkritisches verhältnis auch zu russland
nach wie vor haben also darüber wir
haben auch hier übrigens autokorsos in
berlin mit russischen flecken in zeiten
wo wir das massaker von butscher
gewärtigen müssen also wir haben in
deutschland schon insgesamt einiges
aufzuarbeiten
ich nehme für uns in anspruch dass wir
seit 2014 schon manches gelernt haben
wir sind 42 prozent eingetreten eine
stärkere bundeswehr das war in der
großen koalition noch nicht durchsetzbar
jetzt will des bundeskanzlers scholzen
also die deutsche politik ist glaube ich
insgesamt lernfähig aber wir müssen uns
dafür auch zeit nehmen also für nord
stream zwei irgendwie besser einfach nur
noch mal zu platzieren doch jede menge
befürworter in der union mit
selbstverständlich außerhalb jeder frage
wir haben das unterstützt ich zähle mich
selber auch dazu das ist vollkommen klar
wir haben schon gedacht dass wenn man es
wenn es vernünftige
wirtschaftsbeziehungen gibt dass es die
möglichkeit auch gibt auch in einigen
politischen grundfragen auch zu
verständigungen zu kommen mindestens zum
ausschluss von krieg aber daran haben
wir uns definitiv gehört und das muss
geklärt werden darüber muss man sich
auch rückfragen stellen was heißt dass
der kollege schmidt recht was heißt das
für china
das heißt das für den für den umgang mit
anderen totalitären regimen die wir auch
der welt ja auch noch bedauerlicherweise
haben haben wir bei der früheren großen
koalition so ein bisschen die situation
mitgehangen mitgefangen aber schauen wir
nach vorne das was sie beide ja auch
reklamiert haben schauen wir auf dieses
100 milliarden sogenannte sondervermögen
ich sage immer gerne sondern schuld weil
vermögen das hat man irgendwie aber das
soll ja ausgegeben werden insofern bin
ich mit dem begriff nicht so ganz im
reinen auch wenn das haushaltstechnisch
tatsächlich so heißt diese 100
milliarden wird seitens der union
gelegentlich bezweifelt ob die
tatsächlichen die richtung ausgegeben
werden und dafür ausgegeben werden wofür
sie aus sicht der union zumindest
ausgegeben werden sollen wie wird das
verfahren sein herr schmidt gibt es ja
schon ein bisschen mehr erkenntnisse
darüber weil die union fordert ein
mitspracherecht haben wenn sie das mit
verabschieden soll weil eine
grundgesetzänderung nötig ist helfen sie
uns ein bisschen also selbstverständlich
wird die union mit einbezogen aber wir
wollen ja gemeinsam das grundgesetz
ändern und ich meine zunächst mal müssen
wir den text definieren der diese
grundgesetzänderung zu grunde liegen
soll das heißt über den text wurde auch
die zweckbestimmung dieses
sondervermögens genau festgelegt und für
uns ist klar es geht um die bundeswehr
um die stärkung der
verteidigungsfähigkeit und dann werden
wir jährlich im haushalt festlegen wie
viel aus dem sondervermögen entnommen
werden muss für bestimmte
rüstungsprojekte
das kann naturgemäß
noch nicht so konkret seien vielleicht
für die haushaltsjahre 22 22 sehr
konkret für die folgejahre brauchen wir
da auch eine gewisse flexibilität aber
ich glaube wir werden uns damit union
einig denn wir haben das gemeinsame ziel
dass die ausstattung der bundeswehr
massiv verbessert werden muss da haben
wir nachholbedarf da geht sie mit da
gehe ich auch mit dem verfahren also dem
kollegen schmidt nämlich ab dass wir
beteiligt werden nur bis heute geschieht
es nicht dass es etwas bedauerlich das
müsst ihr nun auch langsam geschehen wir
sprechen in der tat über den
verfassungstext jetzt wir wollen
eigenartige rolle für die union als
opposition nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als dass die aussage von bundeskanzler
scholz ersten 200 milliarden für die
bundeswehr 22 prozent ab jetzt und
dauerhaft dass diese aussagen umgesetzt
werden wenn das geschieht dann sind wir
im boot ich habe keinen zweifel dass die
spd das in ihrer ganz übergroßen
mehrheit will bei den grünen habe ich
zweifel das muss innerhalb der ampel
geklärt werden aber wir sind da
konstruktiv wir setzen in diesen fragen
nicht auf fundamental opposition wir
beteiligen uns wir haben eigene
vorstellungen dazu wie das in der
bundeswehr verwendet werden sollte aber
wir wissen auch wir regieren jetzt nicht
und wenn diese mindestbedingungen
umgesetzt werden dann werden wir uns
daran konstruktiv beteiligen gucken wir
auf 42 punkte wenigstens gekürzt noch
thematisiert kriegen die im moment in
dieser diskussion eine große rolle
spielen das eine ist dass energie
embargo gegenüber russland herr schmid
wie lange wollen sie das noch
durchhalten weiter gas und öl aus
russland zu importieren nach deutschland
bei kohle scheint er jetzt zu einem ende
zu kommen durch die eu kommission ist
kennen alle wirtschaftlichen argumente
die da eine rolle spielen aber sind noch
tragbar angesichts der lage in der
ukraine muss man jetzt vor einem
moralischen hintergrund einfach sagen so
feierabend wir suchen nach alternativen
auf der stelle und wir drehen im
berühmten gashahn jetzt von uns aus zu
also bei öl und kohle haben sie ja zu
recht darauf hingewiesen da sind wir
dabei ein ausstiegs ziel ein
ausstiegsdatum festzulegen zusammen mit
den europäischen partnern und das kann
auch relativ rasch geschehen nach allem
was zu hören vom
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bei gas
komplizierter und da halten wir daran
fest wir können nicht aus einem
moralischen impetus heraus eine sanktion
verhängen die uns auch in große
schwierigkeiten bringen und die
dauerhaftigkeit der sanktionspolitik und
die nachhaltigkeit auch unserer
wirtschaftspolitik gefährdet denn der
ukraine ist ja nicht geholfen dadurch
dass wir uns selber schädigen sondern
dass wir weiteren sie finanziell und
militärisch unterstützen
und ich glaube nach den massakern in
butter und wahrscheinlich auch ein
anderer stelle kommt es mehr denn je
darauf an mit waffen liefern konkret den
militärischen abwehr kampf der ukraine
zu unterstützen und genau das wollen wir
tun ein bisschen was kriegen wir noch
hinter merz hat friedrich merz gefordert
auch nord stream 1
quasi abzuschalten wenn man das so
formulieren kann ist das immer noch
position der union ja selbstverständlich
wir sind für mehr entschiedenheit und es
ist bedauerlicherweise so alles was wir
an russland zahlen in welcher währung
auch immer hilft ende putin diesen krieg
fortzusetzen und wir wollen nicht dass
putin gewinnt sondern dass die ukraine
gewinnt und wenn das ernst gemeint ist
das jetzt wirklich die waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine effektiver und schneller
und werden dann wäre das sehr gut und
wichtig aber es muss auch geschehen das
was bisher da er seitens insbesondere
der verteidigungsministerin geleistet
worden ist das ist mehr chaos und
unstimmigkeit und deswegen ist die
bundesregierung hier gefordert jetzt
endlich effektiver zu werden und dass
man an dieser stelle so stehen lassen
vielleicht widerspricht der
bundeskanzlerin schon gesehen habe im
plenarsaal auf dem monitor den ich hier
in dieser richtung habe der ist schon da
sie dürfen jetzt auch ganz fix reingehen
danke dass sie heute mittag bei uns
gewesen sind vielen dank herr wadephul
vielen dank herr schmid und mir meine
damen und herren schauen direkt rein in
den plenarsaal